بعد فرنسا انضمت بريطانيا الى قائمه الدول
التي لا تستبعد امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات
مقاتله هذا يعني مزيدا من التصعيد في
الحرب وايضا المزيد من الجدل في المعسكر
الاوروبي موسكو لم تخفي قلقها من دخول
اسلحه الغرب المتطوره الى اقرب نقطه لها
سيما مع الزخم الاخير في الدعم العسكري
لكن يبدو ان اكثر ما يثير خشيه الروس
دبابات الالمانيه التي اوشكت على الوصول
بوتين نتحدث عنها بشكل صريح في كلمته
بمناسبه الذكرى الثمانين لمعركه
اتهم الغرب باعاده القتال في اوكرانيا
بايادي خلفاء هتلر عبر هذه الدبابات وقال
لدينا ما نرد به على ارسال هذه الدبابات
الى كياس
للاسف نرى ايديولوجيه النازيه عادت لتشكل
خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا ونحن مضطرون من
جديد ان نجابه عدوان الغرب الذين يهددوننا
بدبابات الالمانيه ويريدون الان ان
يحاربوا في اوكرانيا على ايدي خلفائه هتلر
القلق الروسي لا يتوقف على الدبابات
فاحضان الغرب التفت حول كييف اكثر
والمساعده العسكريه زادت وفي جديدها اليوم
فرنسا قررت تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه رادار
للدفاع الجوي لتتبع الصواريخ والطائرات من
دون طيار القادمه من المنطقه المحيطه
بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
وصف نظام الرادار جراوند ماستر 2008 بانه
فعال للغايه وانه سينقذ ارواح الاوكرانيين
وفي الاثناء انضمت بريطانيا الى فرنسا
واعلن وزير دفاعها بين والاس بانه لا
يستبعد امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل لكنه اعتبر انها لن تكون
عصا سحريه تغير مسار الحرب بسرعه مضيفنا
ان بلاده منفتحه لبحث جميع انواع
المنظومات الحربيه مع اوكرانيا وليس فقط
الطائرات
الاسبوع الماضي قدمنا الدبابات وماذا بعد
ذلك يمكننا ان نعيد به نعد باشياء اخرى
كما قلت في مجلس العموم انا منفتح جدا
لبحث جميع انواع المنظومات وليس فقط
الطائرات لمساعده اوكرانيا هذه الاشياء لا
تحدث دائما بين عشيه وضحاها لكن يمكنني
القول اننا لا نعرض الاوكرانيين للخطر حتى
لو اعلنا تقديم طائرات سيستغرق ذلك شهورا
لا توجد عصا سحريه في هذا الصراع المروع
بخلاف الخطر الحقيقي للغايه هل متمثل في
ان شباب اوكرانيا يضطرون الى النهوض
والمضي قدما والقتال واستعاده الاراضي من
الرؤوس